und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka guten
abend
man kann leider zu sehen wie deutschland
in die dritte welle marschiert fast
12.700 neu gemeldete fälle und die
inzidenz ist auf über 76 gestiegen
das rk ii befürchtet dass spätestens an
ostern die zahlen wieder so hoch sein
werden wie zuletzt an weihnachten
eigentlich soll beim überschreiten von
incidents wert 100 die von bund und
ländern vereinbarte kroner notbremse
greifen
aber ob das dann auch so geschieht kann
man bezweifeln das bundesland
brandenburg zum beispiel hat für sicher
schon entschieden dass es eine notbremse
erst ab 200 zu greifen soll
derweil ist unser nachbarland polen
pandemie schon einige schritte weiter
mit instanzen weit über 200 mecklenburg
vorpommern versucht sich abzuschirmen
mit verschärften einreise regeln und
test vorschriften susanne seine
berichtet es ist ein pressetermin fast
als ob das corona nicht gäbe
ministerpräsidentin schließlich kommt
zur neueröffnung des testzentrums am
grenzübergang linken um es den vielen
grenzpendlern in der metropolregion
stettin leichter zu machen hat das land
mecklenburg vorpommern zwei grenznahe
testmöglichkeiten geschaffen
hier soll alles unkompliziert und
schnell gehen
die schnelligkeit ist ja das ist alles
online läuft und dass die leute halt
keine große verweildauer hier vor ort
haben die sind eingecheckt die kommen
hin
der ganze prozess dauert neunzig
sekunden und dann wieder weg pendler
mario stark schick ist froh dass er sich
jetzt direkt an der grenze testen lassen
kann
er pendelt täglich nach polen zur arbeit
braucht alle vier tage einen negativen
corona test protest seit er hier zehn
euro subventioniert durch die
landesregierung dennoch bleibt es eine
finanzielle belastung für ihn denn er
hat schon gehört das land mecklenburg
vorpommern will künftig von den pendlern
in der deutsch polnischen grenzregion
noch mehr tests alle zwei tage müssen
sie dann nachweisen dass sie frei von
corona viren
wir müssen für jeden test zahlen die
kosten werden steigen es wird immer
länger dauern den test zu machen und
über die grenze zu kommen
grund für die verschärften regeln die
infektionszahlen im nachbarland polen
schnellen in die höhe
die krankenhäuser drohen an ihre
belastungsgrenze zu kommen
seit gestern haben sich dort über 21.000
menschen neu infiziert jeden moment wird
erwartet dass polen als hoch incidents
gebiet eingestuft wird
ab dann will mecklenburg vorpommern die
einreise regelungen für das nachbarland
verschärfen
wir sind mitten in der dritten welle
gerade in polen aber auch in tschechien
gibt es sehr hohe instanzen auch
aufgrund der mutation und deswegen finde
ich es richtig dass wir in den
grenzregionen noch mehr testen für die
metropolregion stettin wo viele deutsche
und polen auf beiden seiten arbeiten und
wohnen bedeuten die einreise regelungen
eine belastung
das ist für uns ein stark vernetzt das
zusammengewachsene region geworden also
wir haben fordert die die grenzen nicht
gespürt und jetzt ist sie zu ihren
ursprünglichen bedeutung zurückgekehrt
und so stellt die pandemie und das leben
in den grenzregionen ganz besonders auf
die probe nicht nur in deutschland auch
in russland wird im september gewählt
dort stehen parlamentswahlen an
viel zu befürchten haben putin und seine
regierungspartei nicht der russischen
opposition fehlt es an schlagkraft erst
recht seitdem regimekritiker navalny in
einem straflager verschwunden ist
doch auch das reicht dem kreml offenbar
noch nicht bei einem treffen russische
oppositionelle heute gab es massenweise
festnahmen
christiansen berichtete aus moskau wenn
sich oppositionelle in russland zu
gesprächen treffen wollen kann das in
diesen tagen so n
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer eines
forums in einem moskauer hotel werden
festgenommen
über den roten teppich gezerrt
gefangenen transporter stadt
gesprächsrunde rund 200 personen
darunter lokalpolitiker und journalisten
wurden festgenommen
eine halbe stunde nach beginn kam die
polizei und beendete die gespräche
aufgrund von aktivitäten einer
internationalen oder ausländischen
nichtregierungsorganisation die auf dem
territorium russlands nicht erwünscht
sind
sie werden nun alle festgenommen mit der
unerwünschten organisation ist wohl
offenes russland gemeint die
organisation des im exil lebenden
russischen oppositionellen michael
rogowski jeder versteht welchen preis
man dafür zahlt und warum er hier ist
jeder versteht was hier diskutiert wird
wie russland in den kommenden 100 jahren
aussehen soll wenn man dafür so etwas
durchmachen muss es sollte das größte
oppositionskräften des jahres werden vor
allem um sich zu koordinieren nach dem
prozess gegen alexej nawalny und vor den
anstehenden duma wahlen im september und
der frage wie man der kreml partei mit
taktischem wählen stimmen abjagen kann
unter den festgenommenen heute auch
lokalpolitiker die aus dem ganzen land
angereist waren
das sind künftige kandidaten für das
russische parlament und ich denke dass
das signal absolut eindeutig ist die
führung wird keine selbstorganisation
der opposition zu lassen sondern sie
unterdrücken
die verschlechterung der situation in
der wirtschaft sieht so aus als ob sich
die macht auf das schlimmste vorbereitet
in münchen wurde eine veranstaltung mit
mehreren tausend teilnehmern aufgelöst
weil laut polizei verschiedene auflagen
nicht eingehalten wurden
brasilien hat den dritten tag in folge
mehr als 2000 corona todesfälle
innerhalb von 24 stunden gemeldet und
über 85.000 neuinfektionen
gesundheitseinrichtungen warnen davor
dass die krankenhäuser an ihre grenzen
geraten und die lage sich noch
verschlimmern könnte brasilien mit
seinen 210 millionen einwohnern ist
eines der von der pandemie am stärksten
betroffenen länder und verzeichnet
inzwischen etwa 275.000 corona tote in
myanmar sind polizei und armee erneut
mit gewalt gegen demonstranten
vorgegangen
dabei kamen mehrere menschen ums leben
zahlreiche weitere wurden verletzt
seit dem militärputsch vor knapp sechs
wochen kommt es im ganzen land fast
täglich zu massenprotesten
polizei und armee reagieren zunehmend
brutal nach un angaben wurden seit dem
umsturz mehr als 70 menschen getötet
morgens steht ja wieder ein langer
wahlsonntag an mit den landtagswahlen in
baden-württemberg und rheinland-pfalz
für die cdu läuft es in beiden nicht
wirklich gut
bei der spd ist das bild zweigeteilt
katastrophal in baden württemberg die
umfragen deuten auf zehn prozent sogar
weniger als fdp und afd vorhergesagt
wird in rheinland pfalz hingegen stellt
die spd die ministerpräsidentin und malu
dreyer wird den job wohl auch behalten
können und mit ihr hoffen auch fdp und
grüne wieder mit in der regierung zu
sitzen
susanne gelhard schaut auf den
wahlkampfabschluss in rheinland-pfalz
endspurt mit bundesprominenz robert
habeck und eines spiegel
spitzenkandidatin der grünen werben für
erneuerbare energie sie könnte die
königsmacherin sein weil der
wiederauflage der ampel aus spd grünen
und fdp
wir hoffen im rheinland pfalz und in
baden württemberg auch noch mal ein
bisschen rückenwind schön bunt und dann
geht das war ja einfach nicht sich auf
die zielgerade
wir wollen drittstärkste kraft im land
werden und es ist kein geheimnis dass
wir die größten inhaltlichen
schnittmengen mit der spd haben bei der
fdp digitaler rückenwind christian
lindner im studio schmidt genannt nach
der spitzenkandidatin noch vor kurzem
musste daniela schmid um den einzug in
den landtag bangen
inzwischen hat die fdp leicht
dazugewonnen und auch ohne daniela
schmid gegen nicht bei den dreien von
der ampel dann gilt es die
rahmenbedingungen so zu stellen dass
insbesondere unser mittelstand der
einzelhandel aber auch das handwerk dann
gestärkt in die zukunft geht
digitalisierung innovation ganz viele
themen die wir auch positiv begleiten
wollen
frontfrau malu dreyer sie bringt der spd
prognosen von über 30 prozent
sie ist als ministerpräsidentin bekannt
und populär in rheinland pfalz ihre
partei liegt vor der cdu aber knapp also
wirbt sie bis kurz vor der wahl mit
sozialer gerechtigkeit bildung
gesundheit
das wichtigste für mich ist dass die spd
die stärkste partei wird und wenn das
morgen abend sich so raus stellt dann
ist natürlich kommt alles weitere aber
wir haben einen anwalt sehr gut zusammen
regiert und ich kann mir natürlich
dieses gründen ist auch weiterhin sehr
gut vorstellen
cdu spitzenkandidat christian baldauf
hat schon am montag gewählt von der
briefwahl hofft vor allem die cdu zu
profitieren
die bei wahlen zuvor doch keiner weiß ob
die rechnung dieses mal aufgeht bildung
digitalisierung wirtschaft auch
christian baldauf will alles geben bis
zum schluss da kommt die masken affäre
der union ungelegen
das ist schwer zu sagen wie sie es aus
wirklich kann nur sagen wir haben völlig
richtig gehandelt indem wir konsequent
und sofort gesagt haben dass das
unmoralisch ist dass das überhaupt nicht
geht dass die personen auch ihre
konsequenzen zu tragen haben das ist
doch passiert
afg spitzenkandidat michael frisch der
tour weiter in der opposition bleiben
keine der landtagsparteien will mit ihm
zusammenarbeiten um fragen sie in die
afg einstellig er ist optimistisch ich
habe mir mal gesagt 10x die umfragen
deuten darauf hin dass das realistisch
ist und ich hoffe dass ich relativ groß
werden wird wer gewinnt die mehrheit im
mainzer landtag morgen gibt es die
ersten ergebnisse im superwahljahr im
zdf berichtet morgen ab 17 uhr 30 mit
mehreren sondersendungen über den
ausgang der wahlen um 21.45 zu gewohnter
zeit dann auch wieder im heute schon ein
und jetzt nochmal hans zunächst mit
sport zum handball und einem schritt der
deutschen mannschaft richtung olympia
ticket beim qualifikationsturnier in
berlin gewann das dhb team gegen
slowenien mit 36 zu 27
mit einem sicheren andreas wolf im tor
und effektives angriffsspiel lässt das
deutsche team den gästen neben weiß
schon in der ersten hälfte keine chance
auch julius kühn trägt bei zur 22 zu 12
pausenführung gegen die
ersatzgeschwächten slowenen dann ist
natürlich das leben möchte aber auch
natur spiele richtig dass marcel
schiller mit sieben treffern bester
werfer im team erzielt schon nach 44
minuten das dreißigste tor für die dhb
auswahl einen tag nach dem remis gegen
schweden jetzt der sieg gegen slowenien
nach uwe gensheimer siebenmeter zum 36
zu 27
das olympia ticket ist greifbar gegen
außenseiter algerien genügt am sonntag
im letzten spiel ein unentschieden
und jetzt die lottozahlen dieses
samstags sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr
4 19 24 44 47 48 superzahl 8 und weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 55 6 es
gibt unwetterwarnungen des deutschen
wetterdienstes vor orkanartigen böen in
teilen von sachsen anhalt und baden
württemberg und lagen über 1000 metern
und vor starkem schneefall in regionen
im süden bayerns die wetteraussichten
für morgen wechselnd bewölkt und viele
regen schnee und graupelschauer örtlich
auch gewitter starker westwind mit
stürmischen böen höchstwerte 1 bis 10
grad sind auch wenn die nächsten tage
sehr wechselhaft mit vielen schauern
aber auch etwas sonne an den alpen
kräftige schneefälle montag zwei bis
zehn grad danach etwas kälter das war es
von uns die kollegen vom aktuellen
sportstudio freuen sich wenn sie noch
dran bleiben und danach so gegen 0.55
gibt es die letztere tags presse ab
morgen auch wieder lösen
[Musik]